Vsauce! Kevin here.
Hang on a second.
Ah, man. Ah, now I have to pee.
Wait.
Why do we pee and poop in clean water?
I did disinfect the bowl and refill it because the
toilet could contain harmful bacteria -
but the water is fine.
So how did artificial rivers
flowing in and out of a tiny artificial pond
become the most common way to remove waste?
And how does an English poet’s attempt to
sweeten air and an Austrian holocaust survivor's
dirt toilet factor into what a British Medical
Journal poll revealed to be the most important
health problem of the last 150 years?
Poop.
Humans can either poop in the ground and cover
it with dirt or poop in water and walk away.
We’ve pooped in water by building toilets
over canals like the Romans in 4th century
BC, building toilets on bridges like the London
Bridge privies in 1382, or using a hanging
toilet, which is basically a chair at the
end of a dock with a hole in it. Water is
the quickest, easiest way to get poop out
of sight and more importantly to our ancestors,
out of smell.
For much of history, bad smells weren’t
just unpleasant - they were thought to carry
illness. Before the discovery of germs in
1880, the miasma theory was dominant -- it
held that sickness like Cholera, which is
acquired by drinking water contaminated with
feces, was actually caused by breathing smelly,
poison air. The word malaria, a disease commonly
transmitted by mosquitos, comes from the Italian
“mala aria” meaning “bad air.”
The bad air from dead bodies was thought to
spread the plague. The Black Death killed
almost a third of Europe in the 14th century.
1348’s Ordinances For Sanitation In A Time
Mortality in Pistoia set strict rules on sealing
dead bodies in coffins and establishing the
specific depth of their burial. During England's
Great Plague in 1665, the Mayor of London
attempted to prevent plague-ridden stench
from infecting the living by mandating that
bodies must be buried six feet deep (1,82 meters) .
Over two hundred years later, in the wake
of pioneering germ research from Louis Pasteur
and Robert Koch, French biologist Alexandre
Yersin finally found the plague's cause -
bacterium carried by fleas living on rodents.
Smells don’t carry sickness, but they can signal
a biological warning to help us avoid something
dangerous.
Pathogens in human feces cause illnesses ranging
from typhoid fever to hookworm, and we believe
the dislike of odors from bodily fluids is
an evolutionary response to avoid disease.
Odor molecules bind to specialized receptors
in the back of the nose located on millions
of olfactory neurons - which go straight to
the brain where they’re deciphered. Fresh
food is typically safe and typically smells
good. Rotten food is often dangerous and often
smells bad.
And preventing stench and sickness was the
motivation for the john.
The Sir John.
Sir John Harington, an English poet and prominent
member of Queen Elizabeth I’s royal court,
wrote about his flush toilet invention in
1596. But his desire to sweeten the air would
go unfulfilled for centuries.
One reason his technology was ignored was
that the rich simply had no need for a complicated
toilet - they had servants. The Groom of the
Stool, a job which later gave way to the Lady
of the Bedchamber, not only disposed of waste
by emptying the chamberpot, but also literally
wiped their royal butts.
But you don’t have to be royalty to not
want to deal with waste. Individuals generally
leave their waste in the nearest water source,
or a hole in the ground until it becomes someone
else’s problem…
which it usually does.
The Tragedy of the Commons is an economic
theory that describes how everyone acting
in their own self-interest can destroy a resource
used by an entire community. Victorian economist
William Forster Lloyd coined the term in 1833
to illustrate the problem with cows grazing
on shared land. If each individual grazed
their cows without limits, they'd eventually
bring more and more cows until the land became
so overgrazed that no one could use it.
Now imagine a city tripling in population
from one to three million people in just half
a century, with everyone dumping industrial
and human waste into one river. Combine that
with an unusually hot summer and you get stink.
In London, 1858, it was the Great Stink.
Outbreaks of cholera were blamed on the smell
from the banks of the River Thames. Chancellor
of the Exchequer Benjamin Disraeli described
the river as, “a Stygian pool, reeking with
ineffable and intolerable horrors,” and
English physicist Michael Faraday said, "Near
the bridges the feculence rolled up in clouds
so dense that they were visible at the surface."
Social scientist George Godwin documented
piles of untreated waste on the banks as being
up to six feet deep.
The average male height
at the time was about 5 foot 4 (1,65 meters).
The government accepted a proposal from civil
engineer Joseph Bazalgette to build an elaborate
sewer system that carried waste to six different
outlets, each emptying into the ocean.
It took twenty years to complete, but one hundred
years later, the Thames was declared dead.
After wartime bombing destroyed parts of Bazalgette’s
sewer, the Manchester Guardian described the
Thames as a "badly managed open sewer," and
in 1957 the Natural History Museum declared
it biologically dead. Despite resistance to
cleanup, including a member of the House Of
Lords stating in 1959 that breaking up sewage
gave rivers, “something to do,”
waste treatment improved
Advances involved screening
and cleaning the waste before releasing the
filtered water back into waterways -- and
today the Thames once again supports wildlife.
It took nearly three hundred years, improvements
in civil engineering and a public disaster
for Sir John Harington’s flushable toilet
to be widely adopted. And now the water in
toilet is the same water that comes from the
tap. Which, in many areas is perfectly drinkable.
The end.
But wait. Billions of people lack access to
flush toilets. And whether the ground is too
frozen, the land is too dry, or a community
is too poverty-stricken, complex water sewage
systems don’t exist in much of the world.
1.8 billion suffer every year from ingesting
water contaminated with waste.
Flying toilets are used in the slums of Kenya
and Haiti. They’re plastic bags used as
toilets and then flung as far as the user
can throw them. Hitting people, piling on
roofs and bursting open when they hit the
ground - clogging drainage systems and contaminating
water. In India, where more people have cell
phones than access to a toilet, newly-installed
toilets are often ignored because of taboos
regarding cleaning them out. The government
and World Bank developed a “No toilet, no
bride” campaign to influence families to
have a proper toilet before getting married.
The future of poop requires a paradigm shift,
described by American physicist Thomas Kuhn
as a fundamental change in the basic concepts
of a scientific discipline. While spiderwebs
of water pipes pushing waste for centralized
processing was rated the greatest medical
advance in 150 years - Friedensreich Hundertwasser
advocated for a different approach. His solution
was pooping kinda like cats.
Litter boxes play on a cat's natural instinct
to defecate in soft, sandy soil by making
a cat toilet out of moisture and odor-absorbing
material. But instead of throwing the waste
away like owners do with cats, Austrian painter
and architect Hundertwasser’s wanted human
poop to return to its natural purpose.
The humus toilet is a composting toilet that
works by having a layer of humus, at the bottom
of a bucket and then scooping some fresh humus
on top of the poop after each use. With no
bad smell, Sir John Harington would approve.
A double bottom allows for air flow and a
drip-trough and eventually the contents during
turn into fertilizer called humanure.
The word human actually derives from the latin
word humus meaning earth and ground and humanus
meaning man. And the humus toilet, according
to Hundertwasser, represented a direct cycle
of life between people and planet. His concern
was that flush toilets divorce humanity from
a basic circle of life - with waste turning
into fertilizer for plant life. The death
of food becomes the birth of vegetation. Saying,
“What comes out of us is not waste, but
the building block of the world…” And
while poop might not exactly be Lego, it was
worth some money.
Human excrement entering sewer systems was
actually opposed in mid-19th century France
by night soil collectors. Named because they
did their dirty work at night, they didn’t
want to lose their job gathering and selling
poop to be made into fertilizer and pee to
be made into the saltpeter used for gunpowder.
Companies around the world are starting to
see the dollar signs in doody. Utilizing waste
from urban sewage treatment facilities is
gaining steam as technology advances for turning
biosolids into fuel and energy. And toilet
reinventions are underway, including a solar
toilet from the California Institute of Technology
that generates hydrogen and electricity, and
the Cranfield nano membrane toilet which separates
and cleans water from waste. The leftover
is covered in wax to seal pathogens and help
it dry out to be later used for energy.
Waxy poop balls might not be the direct cycle
Hundertwasser desired, but toilet reinventions
represent the unique marriage between humanity
and the planet -- the engineering of Sir John
Harington with the ecological philosophy of
Hundertwasser.
A direct theme of Hundertwasser’s work
was his rejection of straight lines. Preferring
spirals and squiggles, he believed straight
lines were a human construct that separated
us from nature -- and a straight line was
the design flaw in Harington’s toilet.
A straight pipe allowed gas to rise up directly
into the water closet from below. Alexander
Cumming invented the S-trap in 1775, which
allowed standing water to block the foul air.
A squiggly line perfected Harington’s toilet.
But Hundertwasser cared about people and improving
the most basic parts of their lives, saying,
“I want to make people happy. Not depressed.
I don’t want to burden them with more problems
-- they already have enough." He knew problems,
having survived the Holocaust when at least
69 of his family didn't -- and thought that
returning to a state of beauty in our interactions
with nature would ensure our survival.
Hundertwasser believed in the Earth’s cycle
so strongly he used himself as fertilizer.
When he died of congestive heart failure in
2000, he was buried without a coffin, under
a tulip tree only two feet deep. No one visits
his grave - they visit his tree.
Friedensreich Hundertwasser’s circle is complete.
And through this perspective of death and
rebirth, we re-invent our waste and our bodies
- sewage becomes energy, and we become a forest
of the living dead.
And as always
thanks for watching.
Special thanks to Neil Bromhall for the stoning nature footage.
And a extra special thanks to everyone at The Hundertwasser Foundation.